بقينا قاعدين في الدار في امان الله واجت
اجت اليهود خشت على الدور وفتحوا الباب
وقالوا لنا اطلعوا انتم والنسوان في
الشارع انا قاعد على كرسي متحرك يعني عندي
شلل نصفي و اخذونا واخذوا اخوتي واولاد
اخوتي وشلح ونا اواعي في الشارع واخذو عن
طريق السكه وطلعنا وراحوا حملونا حملونا
في الشحن وغم عينينا وحطوا في ايدينا
الكلبشات وحتى قاعد يعص فيها يعني على
الاخر مع انه شايفني انه مشلول يعني ما
بقدرش اعمل
حاجه يعني وحطوه في الشحور وراحوا قعدوا
طول الطريق عدوا يصوروا عليه يصوروا فينا
ويستهل سوا فينا قاعدين يدحو يتقصون
الجنود وبعدين
اخذونا على نقطه شرطه ولما نزلونا من
الشحن الشحن بيجي عليه مترين انا عشان من
عشان المعاق ما نزلوني بشويش راحوا رموني
رامي زي الكلاب هيك فوق بعض
وبعدها قعدوا يسالونا على سمينه ويقعدوا
يقولوا لنا خماس خماس واحنا نقوللهم لا مش
حماس احنا مدنيين احنا كنا في الدار قال
لا انت خماس وينزل فينا
ضرب اخر ليلتين عذبونا فيهم خلونا ننام
طول الليل بس عذاب وذل عذاب
ذل